[Musique]
je
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes à moscou ça y est l'été est
arrivé le pollen des peupliers a
recouvert la capitale et tout le monde a
voulu en profiter pour sortir dehors et
je vais faire de même je vais maladie
la saison estivale est propice aux
sports de plein air et en particulier au
dos rond aujourd'hui nous allons
rencontrer quelqu'un qui s'y connaît en
la matière
[Musique]
notre invité d'aujourd'hui est champion
de russie de motoneige vice champion du
monde de rallye tout terrain en moto il
a même fait le paris dakar
il est aujourd'hui concepteurs de
véhicules électriques légers il
s'appelle arnaud jacquart et me tarde de
vous le présenter allons faire sa
connaissance
c'est un tiens tiens celle d'arnaud
bonjour rien ça fait plus de deux mois
écoute ça fait du bien de se revoir ça y
est enfin un swing et ce magnifique tu
en as tu peux me dire un petit peu
qu'est ce qu'on fait ici
alors ici c'est c'est mon repère c'est
là où je j'expose oui tous les véhicules
électriques légers que je conçois et que
je fabrique tu es donc concepteurs
fabricants de véhicules légers
électriques légers
c'est une première en russie on n'a pas
ça oui il fait un ouais j'ai hâte de
voir ça et bien qu une montre l on y va
raconte moi un petit peu ici c'est ton
show room c'est ça oui il ya tous les
vélos que tu proposes à peu près tous
nos modèles en fait ce sont les modèles
qu'on conçoit qu'on fabrique et qu'on va
donc vendre sur le marché local et on
les conçoit en plus bien sûr pas pour
une mentalité européenne
c'est pas que les européens ont une
mentalité différente mais c'est qu'ici
en fait on a plus de possibilité c'est à
dire quand on ne rend que tu es tout de
suite limité avec
25 km heure tu n'as pas le droit d'avoir
la poignée de gaz et le moteur doit
faire que 250 web donc ici si tu as le
permis m km open
enfin scooter ou le permis de voiture
peu importe tu peux aller dans la rue et
aller jusqu'à 60 kilomètres heure et
jusqu'à 3 kilowatts de puissance donc
c'est le paradis donc tout ça c'est toi
qui l'a dessinée ou taf et a conçu la
majorité des des vélos qui sont ici
alors personnellement moi je suis le
créateur de tout ce que de tous les
modèles qu'on voit ici donc c'est bon
c'est mon dada d'accra partie est une de
mes un ennemi un poids pardon donc je
fais la conception du cadre derrière on
va rajouter tous les tous les composants
qui nous paraissent intéressants à ce
niveau là on va créer un prototype on va
s'amuser à le détruire jusque ce jusqu'à
ce que c'est possible pour comprendre
toutes les failles de ce vélo oui
et une fois qu'on a pour modifier
tourner un jour et voilà les crash tests
eh ben on va sortir le vélo dis moi
c'est quoi tout ça parce que c'est une
bande
didon ya la victoire apparemment il ya
des petites coupes ouais ouais ouais bah
c'est aller ça a commencé en 2001 et
2000 en gros ça c'est la victoire du
championnat de russie en enduro ça c'est
ma première victoire à l'international
quatrième place au rallye du maroc
hockey à pied du podium
alors après ça a été plus sérieux on
arrive à la première place africains
restent open et la deuxième place place
par donc au scratch
moi ce que je veux voir c'est la plus
belle victoire alors là elle est où
cette deuxième place à vice champion du
monde alors vice champion du monde
écoute la voix là bas c'est donc 2009 de
mémoire donc ses médailles d'argent aux
championnats du monde
rallye tout terrain moto tt loin de la
première place ah oui cyril després il
est intouchable
c'était un professionnel cyril després
c'est quand même une pointure au dessus
un et moi j'étais toujours un amateur en
fait et très honnêtement une moto
d'usiné une moto de production rien à
voir non celle ci c'est une belle
histoire
enfin une première place que j'étais
tout seul c'est donc je suis le premier
pilote à avoir travaillé à traverser
pardon un désert et on est quel désert
le sahara en moto électrique
donc c'est une première mais bien mis et
première mondiale sera demandée voilà
voilà et c'est le toit est encore le
d'accord le sud du sahara à allah très
honnêtement la course la plus dure de ma
vie mais j'ai jamais être aussi lent
parce que tu dois tu dois gérer la
batterie et j'ai presque pas dormi
pendant quinze jours
et comment au début les dés de
l'électrique 7 et suite à l'histoire est
bien coûte voilà on peut même voir la
photo c'était là sur cette moto là et
bien
je suis j'ai perdu là j'ai perdu la
selle et je perds la selle donc je
reviens 3 4 qui n'entendent arrière et
ensuite je tombe derrière quoi c'est un
un camion à cammas d'ailleurs je n'aime
pas trop calmes et
ils m'ont complètement enfumé j'ai perdu
connaissance et après la délation fini
la police on arrête tout bas c'est le
business jets et voilà et j'ai commencé
par fermer petit vélo dans mon garage et
ensuite je suis dit allez maintenant on
va faire maintenant je me lance là
en plus il avance tout droit devant lui
comme une locomotive
c'est facile de le suivre c'est
quelqu'un de vraiment original
il a beaucoup d'idées de projets je
pense qu'il a des projets pour au moins
cinq ans la peine avec l autre
[Musique]
alors où est ce qu'on est là alors on
est dans le service de notre showroom
ok donc les gars jouaient le garage
voilà donc sais c'est pas en fait
l'endroit où l'on conçoit etc
on a on a un bureau d'études pour ça
mais bon ici ça nous permet d'avoir en
même temps si tu as tous les feedbacks
des clients et de pouvoir rapidement
faire un petit prototype
tu trouves une idée tu te rappelles d'un
autre côté les faits puis tu arrives à
faire un petit symbiose d'un truc qui va
avoir des signatures parce que copier
c'est vraiment pas notre truc tueuse
alors moi je suis tenté de l'essayer
toulouse c'est parce que tu pourrais me
proposer comme moto comme vélo ou est-ce
qu'on peut aller nous avons décidé
d'aller voir ce qu'arnaud fait en dehors
de la capitale à 400 km à l'ouest de
moscou près de la ville de smolensk
arnaud a acheté une ferme abandonnée
pour s'adonner à ses passions et nous y
voilà donc nous nous trouvons dans un
territoire constitué de deux
implantations majeures 600 hectares de
terrain d'accord pour l'agriculture et 8
hectares pour une base de
production donc augmente entre autres
ont produit des types tannique house
comme ça donc ça c'est on va dire pour
le plaisir
ok toujours dans cette mentalité de
matériaux nobles qui sont qu'il ne peut
pas user ta santé si tu vois la ccma
directive c'est la santé le bio que tout
soit 300 ans et c'est ici tu peux
chercher les ondes les 5 g n'a pas donc
tu trouves cet endroit il ya combien que
même temps tu l'as trouvé ça fait un an
que j'ai donc acheté ces 600 hectares et
ses huit hectares de terres mais
stratégiquement pour moi c'est vraiment
c'était voilà j'ai pu mettre tout sous
un toit c'est alors qu'est ce qui a
d'autres ici alors trois axes majeurs la
première chose c'est donc de mettre en
route cette fameuse usines pour la
fabrication de
deux véhicules électriques légers donc
la deuxième c'est donc l'agriculture bio
ou donc on a des projets très
intéressants sur des points bien
spécifiques par exemple assez la
myrtille et myrtille achats d'or ça a
donc je suis gay t on à 16,16 sorte de
myrtilles qui viennent du monde entier
d'accord et donc va en fait comment ça
se passe on fait un projet comprend un
demi-hectare donc 0 05 % de surface et
on fait donc cette ct c'est jusqu'à
maturité et donc tout ça bah on le
commence le plus tôt possible parce que
ça prend beaucoup de temps
un des myrtilles pour la maturité c'est
entre 3 et 5 ans le troisième axe alors
c'est quoi alors le troisième axe est
bien par la force des choses c'est le
bois et y en a beaucoup en russie en a
beaucoup en russie et on a énormément
ici et on travaille un produit bien
spécifique qui s'appelle l'eau le noir
l'eau noire de l'aulne non c'est quoi
ces particularités
alors la partie jean de losne ce qu' il
est très acide d'accord pour beaucoup de
ces myrtille
de b et c il faut que tu prennes 7,6
n'eurent way pour la mettre dessus
inquiète de façon à ce que le ph reste
plus à cette possible donc je résume
d'un côté les myrtilles l'autre côté les
lots mis aux arrêts syrie lecture but en
général l'agriculture m'arrêter là le
but du jeu c'est d'arriver en totale
autonomie
je prends la synergie si tu veux rien ne
se perd tout se transforme
soit vraiment ici à son apogée
[Musique]
arnaud est complètement tournée vers
l'écologie d'aquarelliste ici tous les
projets que nous menons avec arnaud sont
entièrement naturel sur ce plan nous
nous comprenons bien les personnes qui
parlent en russe il est très attaché à
une idée parfois ses idées semble folle
mais les idées folles me plaisent
comment est-ce que les écrivains
écrivent des livres où les poètes des
verts probablement comme arnaud sauf que
ce ne sont pas des verts mais des idées
[Musique]
arnaud jacquart né en 1972 à saint maur
des fossés en région parisienne
son père l'a directeur commercial d'une
importante entreprise et sa mère est
institutrice enfants turbulents
il s'adonne à de nombreux sports dont
déjà la moto des études en bts de
management hôtelier le conduisent une
première fois en russie où il effectue
un stage en 1991
deux ans plus tard après son service
militaire et une formation
complémentaire en management à lausanne
arnaud repart en russie pour le compte
de la société sodexo
pendant trois ans il travaille comme
responsable de la base vie sur des sites
d'extraction de matières premières il
voyage ainsi dans toute la russie et
fait même plusieurs séjours au delà du
cercle polaire
après un nouveau passage à moscou il
décide cette fois de créer sa propre
entreprise de restauration et grandit
peu à peu jusqu'à inclure plusieurs
restaurants et une chaîne de boulangerie
installée pour de bon à moscou il
rencontre sa première femme alexandra
avec qui il aura deux enfants
à cette époque à
nous se remet à une vieille passion
d'adolescent la moto il participe à
plusieurs compétitions nationales et
devient champion de russie en moto
enduro puis en motoneige fasciné par la
course mythique du paris dakar
il se lance dans le rallye africa reis
qui en reprend le parcours original et
finit deuxième après une médaille de
vice champion du monde de rallye moto il
décide de revendre son entreprise de
restauration pour se lancer dans des
véhicules électriques à deux roues
arnaud crée alors une nouvelle société
pour distribuer ses tout nouveaux
produits sur le marché russe
il se lance même dans la conception de
nouveaux modèles qui fait participer à
des compétitions internationales
c'est aussi à cette époque il se marie
pour la seconde fois et valeria qui lui
donnera un enfant
salut les miettes
comment ça va salut très bien tu peux
m'expliquer un peu ce que tu fais ici
non concrètement ici pas grand chose en
général je suis au bureau je m'occupe du
développement jed arnaud dans ses
différents business
tu ne l'appelle pas papa travaille au
travail au travail
arnaud il doit y avoir une frontière
entre les relations familiales et le
travail
il faut que ce soit clair et donc oui
arnaud c'est pas difficile de travailler
avec lui parfois oui merci c'est ça
aussi tu fais de la moto oui depuis tout
petit j'ai vu que tu es petit tu as quel
âge tu as quand c'est ton père qui t'a
pris ou bien c est donc qui t'a appris
ou papa je ne sais pas pour ça c'est
papa pour la moto j'en fais depuis l'âge
de 5 ans pour le vélo j'en fais avec lui
depuis l'âge de 14 ans
[Applaudissements]
bon yann ouais t'as choisi le vélo
yes on va faire un petit tour vas-y
quand tu veux à nyon montreux mais ce
que je sais faire vas-y aller 1 2 3
pardi
ouais je crois que j'suis pas sur le
banc d'engins a pas le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois que c'est arrivé au bon endroit
tu y as les bienvenus quand tu vois très
bien alors on est chez toi et oui voilà
mon petit entre salaire certains
critères
oui magnifique donc c'est ton
appartement oui c'est toi qui a fait
toute la déco oui toute la déco tout ça
c'est moi sympathique non pas contre un
petit peu ta femme tes enfants comment
ça se passe et ma femme ravissante
valeriya est donc en français mon petit
dernier n'accorde tony les histoires
d'hiver russe
tout cela c'est un peu fini pour eux et
ils sont bien contents puis surtout pour
le la santé parce que le petit ici ça
marchait pas il parle russe il parle
français jeu par l'atonie uniquement en
français alors que ma femme elle se
force à parler en russe avec lui toi tu
par le russe couramment bien cher et au
bureau tu parles russe tout en russe
théâtre cinéma tout ça c'est en russe
oui il n'y a plus aucun complètement va
d'ailleurs ce qui fait que le plus
difficile c'est de ne pas justement
appauvrir sa langue
en fait tant à moscou à part avec moi tu
parles jamais en français non j'étais
pas parler d'elle mais j'ai pas trop mal
le français a encore ça va y rester a
trop perdu il ya des petits restaurants
j'imagine que t'a pas oublié de préparer
la cuisine française veut rappeler à
noël
marie vient d'ailleurs je me suis dit
comme ce serait sympa que préparer un
petit poisson un petit poisson votre
poisson moi je suis très mal et si c'est
pas à l'ancien bon alors qu'aussi bien
la cuisine souvent un petit peu pour le
plaisir on plaisir plaisir et pas perdre
la main c'est comme le vélo seront pas
oubliés par rapport à la famille
comprend un petit peu un fait historique
sprev tu veux dire attitudes sont
comment alors voir ça il faut quand même
bien comprendre que ça fait un bout de
temps que j'y suis plus un
le championnat du monde le champion du
monde en date où j'ai donc fait second
c'était 2009
depuis tu te dis non alors je me suis
calmé c'est ça le but non non c'est
juste un petit mot marre de me casser
tous les os des blessés
c'est pari dangereux s est un sport
dangereux et donc
par contre après je me suis mis au vélo
et c'est vrai que ça te grattes un petit
peu la compétition quand tu es quand tu
es dedans et donc voit l'année dernière
non il ya deux ans par dont il ya eu les
premières courses de vélo électrique
dans le désert ouais il fallait que je
la grille et ensuite j'ai ramené le
fiston avec moi est-ce que vous
l'annoncions donc le fiston il a il a
fallu qu'ils gagnent donc maintenant que
le fiston il a aussi la petite villa
libre
ouais ça ne sais pas si c'est fou
[Musique]
moi ce qui m'intéresse aussi savoir
c'est la russie à 30 ans où il ya 20 ans
il ya dix ans aujourd'hui
quelle évolution qu'est ce qui t'a
marqué le plus quand je suis arrivé à 30
ans pour moi mais me dire que les russes
avaient envoyé le premier homme dans
l'espace c'était impossible de
comprendre c'était c'était pour moi
c'était un mensonge et je me suis c'est
pas possible
si tu veux une histoire qui n'existe
plus de nos jours
c'était quand même en trois mois j'ai eu
mais un mal fou je sais pas si je peux
tu te rappeler de ça à le dépenser 300
dollars c'est à dire que c'était
restaurant caviar vodka les serveurs
autour moi même quelques stagiaires
tu imagines je n'ai pas réussi à les
devancer ses 300 dollars cette période
pour moi est un truc complètement
fantastique et je te dis même pas
t'imaginer l'arrivée en france avec six
valises les chiens le caviar
bon je sais même pas comment je m'en
suis sorti mais je m'en suis sortie et
il faut peut-être que je revienne en
russie un de ses gardes après ça a été
très rapide ça a été la remet le diplôme
tous les diplômes en poche bien et en
russie tu voulais revenir tout de suite
directe est ce qui est pour moi le plus
impressionnant c'est la france où je
suis parti et la russie où je suis
arrivé et maintenant c'est le contraire
[Musique]
après une certaine nostalgie de la vie
bien sûr que c'est un non moins cher que
sinon c'est normal
en plus de ça ce tout est lié en plus au
fait que ton âge avancé donc tout va de
pair bien sûr qu'il ya un an je me dis
mais où est là où est la petite folie
que j'avais où j'allais j'allais faire
du n'importe quoi à n'importe quand
c'est intimement lié de toute façon at
on est évolution personnelle est un
petit peu cette folie qui qui qui est
toujours été en moi je la garde dans mes
projets
[Musique]
et tout à la société il ya vingt ans en
sortant nouri nouvelle il ya dix ans il
y avait c'est plus facile avant il ya
dix ans et moins fait moins facile
aujourd'hui c'est comment pour quelqu'un
qui sait faire du business sur une niche
précise il ya encore beaucoup de
possibilités en russie beaucoup et
ouvrir un business maintenant peut-être
étrangement je dirais et comme beaucoup
plus facile qu'avant il n'y a pas
vraiment de choses trop compliquées
il faut arriver avec une idée il faut
avoir son petit projet est toujours des
projets est toujours temps à plein dans
la tête et s'arrête pas là les montres
moi le chemin à l'envers tel projet en
russie
[Musique]
quand il ya une compétition sportive et
pour la france était pour la russie
alors j'ai toujours couru pour la russie
quelle était ta décision la plus
courageuse que tu aies pu faire on va
parler de la russie un pays si on la
plus courageuse de savoir
tourner la page au bon moment quand
c'était vraiment nécessaire avant de
devenir complètement gaga voilà qu'est
ce qui selon toi et le trait principal
et russes être vraiment soin et bon
vivant être vraiment bien dans quoi même
à l'époque des facebook de ceux ci cela
enrayer toutes ces belles femmes etc
mais ce sont des vrais gens voilà ils
sont entiers ils sont entiers moi j'ai
besoin du secret de ton énergie je sais
pas être vaincue sur toute cette énergie
tous ces projets dont secret c'est quoi
bien à pas je pense que c'est voilà
toujours se remettre peut-être en
question et ne jamais se
ce se remette sur soi même se dire oh là
là je me suis créé des problèmes ceci
cela la vie ne vaut pas là ne vaut pas
l'expérience ne vaut pas d'être vécue si
tu la vis pas font enfin pour moi c'est
très simple ce fut un plaisir à très
bientôt
allez à bientôt salut et voilà notre
journée touche à sa fin nous l'avons
passé avec arnaud jacquart un homme
passionnant passionné bourré d'énergie
comme ces vélos électriques
le nouveau lieu de nouvelles
personnalités tout aussi intéressant 12
attendre je vous dis à très bientôt sur
arte france
[Musique]